how's it going guys my name is matt
you're watching code tekken tutorials
today i want to talk a little bit about
how to learn
programming in a general theory now i
was watching some uh
some lex podcast i'm sure you're
familiar with this guy if you're into
programming at all
he does kind of an engineering podcast
i'll leave a link to it
anyways one of his clips and uh
interview with charles isbell and
michael litman
they were discussing how to learn
programming i thought this was really
interesting because
well basically they kind of had a lot of
the same thoughts that i already
kind of had and i thought maybe you know
a lot of people don't really know this
that are trying to learn that watch my
channel and this kind of spells it out
so i just want to kind of react to this
give my thoughts and
maybe we can all learn something about
how we should go about learning
programming
okay so here is the question that
prompts the whole thing i'm going to let
it play
what advice do you have for people that
want to learn
how to program or want to either
taste this little okay so what advice
would you give people that want to learn
how to program basically
skill set or discipline and listen
to how i'm not sure who's talking it's
either charles or michael i'm not sure
which is which to be honest
or try to see if uh
it feels was one of the match i missed
it sorry here we go
yes what stage are they in or what
station where they at in life
oh in their own life it's really quiet
what stage of life are they in
what stage of life are they in that's
the first question he asked
uh for the person who was asking the
question how do you learn programming
and that's a really good question he
goes into it some later
but basically what he says is
you kind of need to know how the person
thinks because there's like
it really depends a lot like do you
already know bullying logic are you good
with logic do you
do not even like get that at all or you
know there's a lot of
there's a lot of little intermediate
steps and one of the big takeaways here
is to start small don't try to do some
big thing
all at once but starting small is huge
so let's see if we can get another few
uh good clips here
okay so here's a little important part i
think that
i agree with so you know my advice if
you're early on
is you know you got the internet there
are lots of people there to give you the
information
find someone who cares about this
remember they've been doing it for a
very long time
take it slow learn the little pieces get
excited about it and
there we go yes understand that most
people that are teaching it
have a lot of experience with it now
like
everybody it's all subjective like
anybody could watch some of my videos
and say oh this guy's a complete noob
but i know what i've done and all of
capable i know what jobs i've landed
with my current coding skills
and i'm pretty happy with it you know so
uh sure that's that's the thing so when
i'm teaching
i don't expect like everybody to
understand everything always try to
explain all the little steps
but he said something that i think i can
learn a lot and that's to get excited
about it i'm kind of to the point where
i'm not very excited about the basic
stuff anymore
and i'm always trying to get to
something huge and getting overwhelmed
so i feel like i could definitely learn
some lessons here but that's
that's it just start small and you
yeah you do have to be excited about it
because something like mentally clicks
when you're excited about things it's
like you
learn better when you're excited i don't
know if you guys have ever noticed that
but
if you're not interested in something it
just doesn't sink in as well at least
that happens to me
okay let's continue a little bit and see
what else he says here then keep the big
projects you want to build in mind
you'll get there soon enough because as
a wise man once said
life is long sometimes it doesn't seem
that long but it is long
keep your big project in mind because
life is long it doesn't seem that long
but it is long
that's interesting you always hear
people say like a life is short
in the grand scheme of things it is but
as far as building things
yeah you can do amazing things in a
lifetime i agree with that
so that's cool that yeah i think he's
right you start small you get excited
about the small stuff you learn how to
piece together you try to work towards
something big
that sounds about right for programming
or doing really kind of anything you
know
another thing that they get into a
little bit is talking about languages
what language to start with and all that
you always hear
about new people starting out being like
i don't know what language to go with
what do i learn with
and really what it comes down to is it
doesn't really matter
it's like what one what one motivates
you to learn or what one's designed for
what you're trying to do for what your
end
goal is so that's where it's at for me
like you know one to get into graphics
and low level programming for
basically performance reasons c plus was
like the way to go for me and i've stuck
with it and i'm happy with it
um but he does talk about let's just
listen here for a second
that lets you kind of see how the thing
works and that's fine too they're all
fine it almost doesn't matter but there
are people who spend a lot of time
thinking about how to build uh languages
that get people in
okay so he says it almost doesn't matter
but yeah there's
there's a lot of a lot of people spend a
lot of time trying to design languages
that are really easy like with automatic
garbage collections you don't have to
think about as many things
and that's that's pretty important but
yeah
in general you just gotta kind of go
with one it almost doesn't matter
because
you may have heard this before and this
seems to be pretty true
once you're good at one language the
rest become pretty easy because a lot of
the concepts overlap
especially for like software design
theory and stuff
a lot of those just overlap so you
really only have to learn some new
syntax
and kind of how the the language works a
little bit but the rest of stuff you
already know
so you just kind of need a language to
dive into to learn all the core concepts
and i think they end up saying python's
a good one uh i would agree
but uh you know whatever whatever gets
you motivated the questions are you
trying to get
in and figure out what it is or do you
already know
what you want and that's why i asked you
what stage of life people are in because
if you're different stages of life you
you would you would attack it
differently yeah that's really big
so i think the biggest thing honestly
the biggest thing
is just to do it you just like start
today
start now start as soon as you have free
time it's like the more you do
them let's let's spin it on a positive
way the sooner you start the more
that like base knowledge starts
accumulating and i think that was really
big for me like
i actually started programming late in
my life compared to most people you know
a lot of people hear about a lot of
people saying i programmed as a kid and
stuff
and i actually sort of did without
knowing it because as soon as we got a
computer i was like
hacking away at that thing all the time
taking it over the you know
my brother could never get on because i
was always messing with it no i'd never
kidding but
i basically kind of learned as much as i
could is
just because i've like messed with the
computer so much so i ended up doing
some
scripting stuff just following tutorials
and stuff and that's sort of considered
coding but i didn't really
realize i was coding until later in life
so yeah i would just say start as soon
as you can that's probably the biggest
thing
and here's another really interesting
part they're talking about like
how it's all really complicated but it's
also really
simple and i totally agree there's only
there's like a very
there's very few things you actually
need to know when you're programming
there's
i think that he says some of them here
and there might it might be a little
more complicated than he's making it out
to be
but also it's a different way of
thinking so let's just listen to it for
a second here and
and uh see what they say i was teaching
intro to us as a favor
it was very funny because i'd go in
every single time and i would think to
myself
how am i possibly going to fill up an
hour and a half oh okay
here he's talking about lecturing he was
doing a little intro to cs
lecture and he was trying to figure out
how he's going to fill up an hour and a
half
but talking about for loops right and
there wasn't enough time
there wasn't enough time that exactly
that's what happens when i do my
tutorials honestly i think
i can bang this out in 10 minutes 15
minutes and then after i'm like blabbing
for a while i look at how long i've been
recording and it's like
sometimes 40 15 minutes i'm like geez i
thought this would only take 10 minutes
of pretty simple stuff
actually so yeah why it's pretty simple
there's a lot to go into and there's a
lot of scenarios but
just to like teach the bass it's like
variables
functions and kind of how the memory
works and you know how references work
if you need references
but just how like the equals and
assignment works and all that
so there's only a few things really to
learn
but there's just like so much little
possibilities of directions you can go
with just for loops and if else
you know it's it's pretty it's pretty
interesting
so it's a little bit more it took me a
while to realize this right
there are only three things right
there's reading from a variable writing
to a variable in conditional branching
reading from a variable writing to a
variable and conditional branching
yeah i'd say that covers a lot of stuff
the conditional branching is very broad
like
i guess that covers the loops the whiles
all the
if else and going to different areas and
setting variables because yeah generally
what you do
you know it depends on the program but a
lot of times
uh you're just going to be setting
variables and then running your current
state based off those variables that's
how a lot of things work they just have
like
their settings and then it runs and as
you go you change the settings or
process input
and you know that's that's the loop of a
lot of programs
it's pretty straightforward
everything else is syntactic sugar
everything else is syntactic sugar
yeah there's that's i don't know it's
hard to say he's wrong you know
uh a little exaggerated but
yeah it's kind of true right the
syntactic sugar matters but that's it
and when i say that's it i don't mean
it's simple i mean it's hard
see now see that's where the trick is
like it sounded simple for a second but
then suddenly it flips to its heart so
what's hard about it
like conditional branching loops
variable
those are really hard concepts so you
shouldn't be discouraged by this
yeah you know i feel like these concepts
become intuitive
they do become intuitive but at first
when you haven't seen them and haven't
messed with them a whole lot they are a
bit
daunting and hard yeah i agree
it's a simple experiment i'm going to
ask you a question now you're ready
x equals three okay okay
this is interesting so he's going to say
some things and check
and see and just like the knowledge of
how
assignments work is interesting
y equals four x equals three y equals
four okay what is x
what is x well x is three of course
right
three what is y four y equals gonna mess
this up
no that's oh it's easier y equals x
now you say y equals x y equals x
what is y and what is y now so that's
pretty interesting
and and it depends is it a reference
is it you know when you're changing
variables you can either
you know they're either in their own
storage area or you're holding a
reference to another one
so if the main one changes then all the
ones that were referencing it
because y could be a reference to x so
if x changes then y changes
or it could just copy the value and if x
changes y stays the same so there's a
lot of little stuff like that that
takes kind of wrapping your head around
and
a lot of it a lot of languages just
don't deal with that they just abstract
that away and don't even let you mess
with it
okay i thought this was another little
interesting antidote sorry about green
screen i'm missing a light it's
a long story doesn't matter but i'm
aware that my green screen is not
perfect right now
all right let's listen to this little
antidote it's it's interesting
anything about programming on those very
basic things
is the the the very basics are not often
made explicit
there we go okay this is something i try
to handle in all my tutorials
the very basics are often not made
explicit
so there's like a newcomer often hit
some tutorial and think okay
i'm gonna learn all this stuff but then
the basics fly at them and they're just
like
i i can't i can't how do i continue when
i don't even know what the heck this
little thing that it is assumed knows so
i don't know just something i've i've
was i strongly realized when i started
programming too
and it's interesting to see other
programmers that are pretty experienced
agree and and know that the thing it
definitely is
let's listen a little bit more to what
lex has to say here which is actually
what
drives everybody away from basically any
discipline but program is just
another one like even a simpler version
of the equal sign that i kind of forget
is in mathematics okay yeah
so he's getting into it you know the you
got to know the exact details of the
basics
and how the equal sign works if you're
doing a reference what it's like in your
language
there's a lot of stuff like that well
that's going to do it for this video
hope you enjoyed hope you're
doing well in your journey to learn
programming or getting better at
programming or video editing or whatever
you do here
or why you're here for this channel i
appreciate all of you whether you're
here for
me personally for the uh videos about
coding or for the videos about video
editing speaking of i do have a tutorial
coming up
about davinci resolve 17. been using it
for a while been practicing and i'm
going to do some basics
on davinci so look forward to that but
yeah that's going to do it for this
video guys thank you so much special
shout out to my patrons
this video is a bit uh live casted
so i'm not going to put them up here but
i will put links down below i appreciate
you guys a lot
and hope you have a great time i don't
just realize what screen i uh paused on
thanks again peace out guys